it seemed the perfect political match
the conservatives and the unionists
but boris johnson's brexit betrayal of
the dup
spelled the end of it facing open revolt
within her own party
arlene foster called time on her
leadership
for almost five and a half years i have
been incredibly humbled
to have the had the opportunity to lead
the democratic unionist party
i have sought to lead the party and
northern ireland away from division
and towards a better path the future
of unionism and northern ireland will
not
be found in division it will only be
found
in sharing this place we are all
privileged
to call home elected members felt she'd
grown weak on the union
not opposed the irish sea border enough
and compromised on social issues
like same-sex marriage and abortion her
departure shifts the party to a more
hard-line position
that could threaten power sharing and
the northern ireland protocol
underpinning brexit there is a
fundamental choice here for the dep
do they go to the left or do they go to
the right it's not entirely clear what
is going to happen yet but i think that
the
instincts of the dep are always to go to
the right that's where the party was
birthed that's what ian paisley
brought these people up on even though
at the end he obviously went leftwards
and became much more moderate
that is what these people instinctively
turn to it's a long way from westminster
but in 2017 arlene foster a politician
from
for mana the uk's most westerly
constituency
found herself front and center of
british politics
holding the balance of power in
parliament
forced from her border home at the age
of eight when the ira
tried to kill her father arlene foster
would later share power with martin
mcguinness
a former ira commander but even here in
her beloved for mana
they were losing faith in her leadership
i think there was time for the overall
of the whole party
not just arlene herself because they
seem to have like one idea in their idea
only
stuff like that so maybe if they have
brought in maybe newer people and
younger people
with more modern ideas and modern
thoughts well
there's so many complaints about her all
the time this notion
she's been in so many different
situations you know
i don't think she's the best leader
from the highs of a deal to keep the
tories in downing street
to the lows of a botched green energy
scheme that brought down stormont
she made her mark on politics but arlene
foster's days as the face of unionism
are over david blevins sky news
in fermanagh